i think it
it it actually doesn't hurt me at all
anymore really because i've i feel like
i i nobody's ever really creative
anymore it's like i see the same thing
over and over again
i think it's more exciting
[Music]
i
like to party jesus honey
this is unwaxed get in loser we're going
shopping with sophia and sistine
stallone do we just become best friends
[Music]
wow guys all right if you have received
any pop culture updates from a celebrity
breakup to bachelorette tea you probably
heard it from these legends sitting to
my left legend host of the wildly
popular podcast chicks in the office
these besties took over the podcast
space in 2017 when they partnered with
barstool sports since then they've
gained over 500 000 followers who are
nominated for our people's choice award
have interviewed countless celebrities
and are currently on tour jesus christ
ladies and gentlemen
what else this is ria and fran
thank you honestly do you ever listen to
that and go like what like we made it
mama we made it i was just thinking
about how professional your guys intro
is compared to when we have guests like
all right we're here with a special
guest okay
great you guys i held my breath the
whole time i'm like panting right now i
was taking those on how you were doing
the intro so that we could use that we
always say we were like should we record
this for our guests and send them as
like a ringtone just to remind them like
they're super like you're about such a
good hype up right yeah i got challenges
everyone needs to hype up it's a good
voice note to have yeah
so i i met you guys oh my god was it
maybe 27 no 2019 yeah yeah i've been on
your show and i was
freaking out you guys gave me so much
clout from like my friends they're like
you're going on chicks in the office i
love chicks in the office it was so much
fun the environment of going to the
studio you girls are so nice i was like
what the hell they're awesome here we
are again we went on your show
and like
we just really appreciate you guys i
know you're busy gals on the go oh thank
you for coming on today we appreciate
you pumped that you guys are here yeah
because i remember we were on zoom and
we were like oh we gotta hang out in
person we gotta do something in person
and finally we're here because it's so
much better at that we're good it's kind
of crazy how many people you've met on
zoom and then you see them in person
like this is just you feel like you know
them yeah in a weird way and then you
say nice to meet you but like you
already met them you know we are on our
conversations right we're already
friends i can envision us having drinks
this weekend at a bar i feel like it's
happening yeah manifesting it for us um
i would love to talk about how you guys
met
so we met at barcelona okay which i
think people get confused by they always
think that either we're sisters or
cousins or
we met before we were zombies yeah
just italian yeah
um but we met at barstool i had been
working there for six months uh prior to
when fran came and i started in like
2016 i was 19. what did you do there i
did a mixture of everything like
basically anything i could do because i
was brought in as an intern but wasn't
really told what i was to do as an
intern like you were like it was very
very scary it's kind of just like you go
and you figure it out and it was like i
would do ran i would be in random videos
i would help out like they needed me to
run to stores and grab them props or
whatever it was that's kind of fun there
was a very classic intern like yeah like
everyone else like you running for
coffee it's like yeah i never lost all
of you in this video
you know so it was like the best world
yeah
the business side of it i think was
way way way smaller at the time like the
company has grown
so much at this point i don't even know
how many over it's like 300 percent or
so
at this point in like
at the time we were on one very small
floor in new york city and there was
like maybe 10 business people at the
time or whatever it was and so i would
help some people on that side i'm just
like doing like excel sheets or whatever
i had no idea how to make one of those
either i was just like i'll do i still
don't yeah yeah
it says
shut up no that's always one of them
excels in excel i took a class like oh i
break like i was going to
the
jokes that they made the day that i was
first hired they were like and she was
hired because she was very proficient in
in excel yeah she's just like i haven't
that's a joke because obviously yeah i
got a powerpoint from high school um so
it was just basically anything that i
can get my hands on and then fran came
in six months later and
kind of had a different type of role
there
sophia and i really love to work power
through things and we often put
our stress on the back burner yeah and i
think also another thing that adds on to
that is when we're traveling especially
right now i mean we're in new york city
and just this whole trip has been kind
of
building up a little bit of anxiety i
don't know
with the work schedule with yeah
managing our family lives our friendship
lives our relationship lives it can be a
lot and it's very stressful and sophia
and i have actually been
using this product that has seriously
changed so much our life and we've
realized that
you don't have to feel stressed all the
time and using prima has actually
changed our entire life but i only even
think people realize that 75 to 90
doctor visits are for stress-related
issues see that's insane it's insane
because many of us are operating all the
time on survival mode we expect our skin
our bodies our minds to thrive when
we're seriously running on empty yeah so
what's great about prima it's california
we're from california it's a lead
purpose-based cbd hemp product that just
is the best way to relieve stress and
why i love them so much is they are
dedicated to helping you rise above
modern day stress so every day is a
little bit better with their doctor
formulated clinically validated high
performance products for the skin body
and mind so if you're not sure where to
start because i know that when it comes
to these products you're just a little
bit overwhelmed they have daily cbd
capsules that you can just take on the
go to relieve that stress i love these
gummies because you know it's fun just
to take a little bit of sweetness
throughout by the way
delicious it's so good kiss or you can
go at night and you use sleep tight
because i know that she also has this
problem we don't sleep i know we talked
about her od on melatonin this has been
the best
alternative i don't have to overdose on
melatonin congratulations
has literally given me some of the best
sleep of my life so lucky for us prima
is offering our listeners an exclusive
limited time
20
offer with the code unwax trust us
because i feel like you guys are
convinced at this point so head to prima
dot co and get that 20 off using the
code unwax and get the relief you
deserve by using the products today
[Music]
as an intern radio though right yeah we
did um so i'm a philly sports fan so
i always followed our
philly guys and so one of them uh smitty
he tweeted out like i'm looking for a
new york intern i was in school in new
york at the time
and i like sent i remember i like sent
it to my mom and i was like should i do
this like i really don't know like
should i send it yeah um and i sent him
an email with my resume all these things
and at the time like
the new york office was so new
and
it kind of just seemed like a
free-for-all so everyone
wanted to work in this mysterious like
new york office right but nobody was
really taking it that seriously so he
said
like he emails me back oh can you come
in whatever tuesday nine pm i'm sure i
mean not am yeah absolutely i'll be
there i show up he's like
i told you and
five other people to show up at 9 a.m
you're the only one here no way are you
serious i was like i'm the only one that
came on time it was like so shocking
that you know people apply for a job and
don't show up yeah no it was nuts and so
like and i was one of the only people
that like actually sent a resume not
just being like give me the job like
yeah i'd fit in a bar stool like yeah
you're like i know sports so here's like
here's actually my resume and um
they were doing a show called drive time
on facebook which was very funny it was
like their morning
a morning show and they brought me on to
help with production for that right um
and then after a little while like they
let me have a mic and we talked and i
was kind of like a female voice on that
which was really fun and then ria and i
got to
talking more and hanging out more and
realizing we had like so much in common
and loved all the same stuff
and
that led to us making our
chicks in the office instagram account
yes oh this is an instagram first yes
started on instagram and we started off
by making like one minute videos of like
the biggest topic of the day
and we we didn't tell anybody we were
doing it like
closet like one camera and we just and
our producer now has been the same guy
that edited the videos from the
beginning he's great wow and
um that's just really how it started
then once we grew the instagram to a
certain amount we took it to dave and we
were like
we've been working on this and he was
like oh it looks like it's doing well
like let's blast it like everywhere like
put it on the website they put it on the
instagrams
then from there um barcelo had
their own siriusxm channel so it was
like radio all day long and they had to
fill the slots and they were like why
don't we you guys want to do like a
chicks in the office radio show where
you do the pop culture news whatever
we had no idea how to do a radio show
obviously i think at that time then i
was 20 years old and you're only 20.
that was the beginning of 2018. yeah we
just had no idea what we were doing but
we're like okay we're gonna do it
obviously we're not gonna say no of
course and we did that every day and
then from there it was like well
podcasts are big and at this time it was
like
who's gonna listen there's so many
podcasts out there and now there's even
more but mostly at that time we were
like there's so many podcasts out there
like who's gonna listen to us and then
we did the podcast and it like exceeded
their expectations like 10 times over
and we were like oh okay we're into it
yeah now that we see how well it's doing
we're in it i would love to get into why
you think your podcast is so successful
because i don't really know another pop
culture i feel like you guys set sort of
the foundation we also get all the tea
before it even yeah it's like i actually
really i'm so honest is it like do you
have a team that gets all that we we do
have we have a we've grown slowly yeah
it's a great little group of yeah noah
our producer and then natalie helps no
with editing editing and then devin who
runs our social media yeah like
everyone's very on top of like when a
news story hits like they put it out
there and they try to be like the good
because you know like
something yeah like devon has devon has
pushed notifications on for everything
smart because i don't have one for
myself
you know when people like re-share a tmz
story yeah yeah yeah that's what we want
to be where it's like when you go to an
instagram story and i do see this now
where people like share the chicks in
the office oh a lot yeah of like what
happened yeah um but i think that
the reason it took off and i think you
know at the time barcelona didn't have
any like female
um hosted shows yeah we were like the
first ones there to do that and so i
think that got eyes on it too it was
like okay this this
brand that was built on all guys now has
this
these this shell with two girls like
let's see what that's about and then all
of the
women who were following barstool were
then excited about that because they're
like oh and then people would show their
wives and their girlfriends they're like
oh this site that i look at all day long
and you're yelling at me that i'm
looking at look at this show that they
have for sure two great women it's
honestly the perfect storm for you guys
i feel like the timing just hit yeah
everything worked out
but sometimes you know when you work
with your best friend or your sister
yeah
[ __ ] gets to the fan yeah crazy
differences like sophia has strengths in
places that i clearly lack and vice
versa
um is there something that you guys like
often disagree about or like i don't
like the way like how do you know like
i think that we both know what our
strengths and weaknesses are like fran
is way more organized and like
facts based
whereas like i'm very much like i just
like to go off the top of my head with
things but i think if it was both of me
it would be
like very messy and like going from this
or whatever and i just like i think we
both bring out the best the best in each
other and it wouldn't work if it was
like two of me or two yeah
that's why it works like if we if we're
starting to talk about a topic
it's it's funny to have like
i'll frame it up okay this is what
happened yeah um what do we think he's
like well that this really reminds me of
you know when i was eight and i were
like all right we're not what where
where did this come from right like we
always get back it's there's great it's
great chemistry i think that is what
sets
our show apart from a lot of others
because when you there are so many
people that talk about entertainment
news yeah um and it a lot of times it
can just come off really straightforward
we try and have be personable more fun
i don't like to just talk about like
straightforward facts of what happened
with the story and yeah people may not
like that some people like i see both i
see some people being like oh we love
the personality and personal stories you
bring to the podcast because
also
i think when you're talking a lot about
celebrities and pop culture and things
that are happening i think it's kind of
shallow to not place yourself in their
shoes and kind of figure out what's
going on because yeah if you're just
talking about it from like a viewer's
opinion yeah then you could be a lot
more judgmental where if you're like
well this happened to me and you can
relate it to them yeah it's just like
it's gonna say see
like
weird if we never talked about yourself
exactly and people are always like why
why do you bring yourself up or like why
does the story always go back to you and
it's like well you try to relate to
these people because they're real human
beings and if you just talk about them
as if they're not real human beings then
it's just kind of sh
c can come across rude or exactly you
are not aware of what you're talking
about i think you guys are also seeing
the trend that being relatable is a lot
more appealing than just being
superficial or surface because it's like
you can say all the facts but if people
are not like loving you guys then how
are they going to want to come back
every single week there has to be like a
consistent yeah you guys give really
good two cents and when you put your
opinion in it's always just appropriate
and respectful and i think a lot of
people like that and i'm sure you have a
lot of listeners that are like oh i like
what they say so i'm going to specially
when you guys do the bachelor stuff i
mean like i don't even know where that
came from because i have to tell you
like i love listening to your commentary
because i agree yeah 100 of it every
single time because you call [ __ ] out
there like maybe i didn't even notice
yeah we're very honest about them it's
so great crazy like you guys really
drove into that franchise and you even
got
luggage guys
yeah on the bachelorette yeah what was
it like what was it about that show that
you're just like okay that's gonna be a
huge issue
um i've been watching the show for like
yeah since high school yeah i loved it i
have always loved it um
and
trent has also like always loved it so
even when we started working so i always
knew that he liked the show yeah and um
he would always lie tweet it i loved to
live tweet it
and
i just it's it's such a major
conversation point
that like shows come and go and people
recap shows but
people who are always going to be
watching the bachelor that's true it's
never going to happen and so i got to a
point where i was like i'm sorry i know
you really don't care about this show
but like it's not good it is going to be
good for us we can have it it's a it's a
opens up an entire world
it's true these are so many people that
go on the show exactly hundreds and you
guys have access to like the hottest one
at that moment we've grown it so much
now
from talking about it so much that we
have created a a fairly decent
relationship like with abc oh and
they're priced awesome they give us you
know the bathroom the bachelorette every
season for interviews and not they don't
do that for a lot of podcasts
awesome and it has been really awesome
and has helped our podcast i think a ton
like i think getting into it so i am
those are some of our biggest stars
like i i do love hate relationships i
have a lovely relationship but i also
think it's a good thing because i do
think even if people because
it's a lot of the people who are very
loud about it that are like the most
dedicated fans but there are casual
viewers who for sure watch it to hate on
it or make fun of it or you just have
all the [ __ ] out on it yeah that's
where i come in where i'm like i'm
watching every episode i'm not saying i
love this show but like the drama is
very entertaining and i will say
my thoughts on it and i think that there
are maybe they're not like vocally
saying it but there are a lot of people
who agree with what i'm saying i want to
listen to a recap of three people who
all have the same opinion no i agree
with that yeah because then it's just
gonna be the same tune exactly i
actually prefer paradise more than that
i
i love like switching it up i like wells
being the bartender but i really loved
when david's
i agree with you guys you guys were
saying you want to be the host why the
hell is he not the freaking i'm sorry
like the other guy he's good at the
bachelor yeah
something exclusive with baby
we've been you've shared for a while now
that we want to do like hosted date or
whatever and they're always like such a
great never say never and we're like
okay well when are you
one of the challenges at least like
being one of the judges yeah like
something like that that's what i'm
saying on the show they put like jessie
on the street whatever his name is i
don't know doing that stuff but like you
guys can easily do like the funny yeah
if the girls are all messed up
is there any drama because you guys do
have a lot of um
i guess couples that would date on the
show and you interview a lot of them has
any of them you know brought that up to
you like oh
like they spill the beans they talk [ __ ]
about someone else that you've had on
that you're friends with like is there
ever any like awkwardness for you guys
not not as much it is fun because
getting to know a lot of i love almost
all the people that we interview that
come from the bachelor yeah because
they're all
normally very open and honest right and
that's nice we can like create
relationships outside with them which
are so fun because then that's like what
yeah they tell us what's going on
right right right yeah
recording the podcast
you guys could be matchmakers honestly
at this point like you because you guys
know a lot of them you can be like oh
this girl would actually be a great
absolutely love to talk please tell me
you've done at least once
bristol and jason
are basically a couple because of us
what i mean we tell this story all the
time she's like not today we tell the
story all the time and they've told it
too that yeah we had caitlyn on our show
we had jason on before caitlin we had
jason and we talked to jason about
caitlyn and he's you know there was like
some flirtation going on yeah and they
had done a podcast together and they
just did
caitlin's podcast oh and then we had
caitlyn on and we were like what do you
think about jason
you know he was here he seemed a little
interested you guys have a little party
like there seemed like there's maybe
some flurries
she planned
when you guys recorded caitlyn's podcast
and she's like she like was giggling and
she was like oh like i don't know if i'm
like fully ready to be like dating
because it wasn't it was after obviously
her breakup totally when they say that
that means they're secretly ready yeah
right and also they were probably
texting
like
i'm sure in her mind she was like am i
really going to date another person like
from the bachelorette
yeah oh it's become so big yeah i feel
like everyone is kind of a part of it in
some ways
coach and my god
for that thing
i mean
oh i'm not gonna lie okay we're gonna be
so honest blake i'm sorry if you're
watching this you're probably not
i
went there with the intention of like
making fun of it because i was like oh
my god
totally different song away all right no
killed it but it was fun because it was
every song that you knew yeah and then
you could just tell how excited it was
but it was funny because everyone from
that show oh yeah every time you like
pivoted your body you would see another
oh
it's good that he just dove into that
right like he just owned his whole
stagecoach thing and then ended up
performing like i know i there there was
one video that was going around i didn't
go to stagecoach but a lot of my
girlfriends went and they loved the
bachelor and they all went to his
set yeah and they were sending videos
and i was like oh man he did like a
fallout boy like it was like yeah went
down down down and it was like it had
just like a great drop but i was like
blake yeah i was like i
was like i really love this remix
yeah i love it because he went from like
shania twain to like baby justin bieber
and i was like all right a little suss
but i'll go with you yeah
we'll go with it yeah that was
incredible epic um so i love that you
guys set up uh jason and chris
like a week later they were posting from
their like first date definitely you
guys yeah and you're like oh this
yeah yeah they've given it to us you
guys brought that up because last time
sophia and i were on your show we did a
zoom interview and you would ask me
you're like oh do you think tyler
cameron is cute yeah and i was like okay
well i wonder if they actually had a
success because it wasn't a successful
set up but i wonder if they did have one
and i mean you guys better be invited to
the wedding like a flower girl or
something
we were just discussing that um they
have two golden retrievers
that are so freaking cute so cute and i
was like do you guys i'm assuming you
guys would want your dogs like as part
of something yeah they were like jason
was like yeah i was like we'll watch the
dogs yeah like we'll just be the don't
be like your dog can handle this
yeah we can just like join the buffet
and like get a plate and then just hang
out with the dogs
sit with the table yeah
we're not gonna know them anyway it'd
probably be uncomfortable like we're
better off just hanging out that's so
you guys can like podcast in the park
while you're like watching from a
distance i love recap they're awesome i
love it yeah well your podcast is fun
because you do discuss a lot of like
breakups and you know celebrity beef and
whatnot has any celebrity ever like
clapped back at you guys like i did see
justin bieber responded to
right so that's why i was openly
tweeting about how terrible she was and
she was not happy with me and everyone
was scared for my life oh
that's fair yeah yeah yeah i was quite
in the documentary justin bieber is the
biggest one which is so upsetting oh i'm
blocked by chris jenner but that's not
even from
what
why are you that's not from the show
that's not from the show that was from
when i was like 14 years old
and i'm still blocked it's sad because i
never changed my twitter i've had the
same twitter since i was like literally
12 years old maybe which was a mistake
by me because i probably should have
just made a new one but whatever at this
point um and when i was like 14 years
old i would tweet at chris jenner all
the time
like being like
i don't know i was like really mean to
her and i love and i love chris jenner
though like i love her she's like i was
manifesting podcasts yeah and i wouldn't
i don't even know
honey call it really mean i think i was
just like
passionate like passionate about the
kardashians and like i just followed it
very closely and okay i think i was
joking around a lot but like maybe
through the internet it doesn't come
across as joking around like right i
remember that when uh kendall jenner
walked uh i think it was a michael kors
runway once i know exactly
um and i was like i said i was very
young and also probably joking around
like yeah yeah like i don't when you're
14. it's not like yeah
yeah and kendall jenner walked i'm
pretty sure it was michael kors and she
like you get to see her
boobs i remember her first time
showed her boobs and i tweeted at chris
jenner like how can you let your
daughter like walk around like this i'm
a 14 year old girl like i'm not a mother
of being like christian
education is really like really getting
raised
but she's like oh cover
jesus christ now i'm walking around with
my nipples blaring on the streets of new
york city but so funny and then i got
blocked and i'm still blocked to this
day but i love chris jenner and i admire
chris jenner but i am shut up never
getting unclocked and
now if she hears that she blocked me
she's gonna be like i'm never gonna
forgive this girl yeah
yeah what are your thoughts a lot of
mixed reviews i was really excited the
first two episodes we got like a
screener for it and we watched it and i
was really excited and i was like oh my
god like this seems like so real like
this just seems like so much more real
than the old show and we're getting like
a behind-the-scenes look and then as the
episodes went on i was like starting to
feel fake again like i don't i don't
know why
i don't feel like it seems real yeah
like as it went on i was like i was too
perfect yeah it's like the they're
walking it's like no shade to you guys
but it looks like a music video every
time you walk into your house yeah and
it's looking like it's looking more like
sun sunset yeah it really does
everyone's in a cat suit the whole time
and maybe i got this from your podcast
or still like i just knew this but
probably
about this from your podcast was it that
they had to like reshoot everything from
astroworld so the timelines didn't like
make sense i think that's why things got
really messy like
this an episode came out the episode the
fifth episode was like chris jenner's
birthday
and
that is right around when actual world
happened and that was actually a big
story line and they were like all there
and they were filming and they cut it
all right so like then they threw in
this weird like
kendall being like i'm in miami and i
care about my health and wellness and
here's my friend haley and we're getting
ivs yeah i was like oh it was like my
friend haley like we know no i mean
haley bieber i was like it was like 10
minutes of watching it and you're just
like this feels extremely out of place
and that's because it was excellent yeah
that's why i had to cut around all the
bad stuff i know i was like you're being
you're a hypochondriac you're saying but
why are you in miami getting health
stuff when la's probably one of them
like health mecca's
i know yeah i think they've really tried
to like figure out a way to plug that
which i don't know i i understand that
maybe
just because
of the magnitude of like what happened
they didn't want to put anything in it
yeah but i do think they could have
shown
something about it or like even after
have just acknowledged that it happened
yeah i was not acknowledging it is like
we all know what happened like even if
you even just like put up a black screen
and robot like and then this happens
yeah exactly and that's usually better
because everyone knows okay like you're
not shying away from it and you're right
there's an issue here the show is just
go completely
about all these
the whole family's life and that's like
a major moment they just did not i think
the weirdest part about the whole show
is um scott's like
persistence to be friends with all of
themselves you all gotta get him on your
show are you guys still in l.a or yeah
yeah
like in between really yeah her
boyfriend lives in new york yeah okay so
she's here a lot and then my parents
moved to florida and i'm in l.a so we're
all bouncing all over the place yeah
what's your favorite spot i'm sorry i
totally know you're please please
i think for me right now i've lived in
alley my whole life went to school there
like my entire life is there but now my
parents are in florida mm-hmm and i'm
all the parents are going to florida
oh where are you in florida west palm
palm beach
my parents are in jupiter
now but like i like miami a lot yeah and
i feel like that would be the next time
i don't know if i could live in new york
is great i was i was saying today
because someone asked me like what's
your favorite city and i was like you
know what i actually hate all of them
yeah
i like i like i don't like living in l.a
like i just hate the people the dating
scene sucks yeah everyone thinks the
[ __ ] don't stink yeah new york is fun to
visit but it swallows me alive i don't
have them here like it's just too
aggressive i'm i'm just like too weak
around here and then miami is a little
bit ratchet so i'm like where do i go
and i think sophie and i are you know
discussing possibly moving to my mind
actually yeah i feel like you guys would
have fun in miami
in new york back and forth oh yeah and
miami to new york is you just there's so
many so
many fights so you guys don't love l.a
like the scene and the dating life and
just from two people who have
visited la
quite a few times and every time we
leave and we go
never live here and we yeah we don't
like the people here obviously there's
some gems we've met some great people in
l.a let me know where they are
we've got good times but
i i the last time we were there i it was
one of the worst experiences i've ever
had and i said i hate this where did you
go out did you guys go out so we went to
um hyde right and uh
i'm not gonna judge because like that's
like one of the last few good ones no
and so we went and it was just like
but it's weird it was also we were there
super bowl week yeah yeah and they were
having it like it was an event right
like
it was i'm still not defending their
behavior of how they opted
the people that were there no not at all
i'm just saying like i don't think like
maybe the crowd that was there is like
the usual crowd that's there because it
was super big yeah yeah it was a
trillion
tick talkers there yeah there are people
stuck up there people think that yeah
yeah and we've and it was like wait it
was just like the way that they were
acting and and um our friend the person
who runs our social media devin was with
us and
um these these tick tockers they're we
were brought into this table because we
were with other people who knew them it
was like a whole thing
and they were physically pushing us out
of the table like it wasn't like the
trailer kids yeah like fit like physical
but also like pushing us out of the
bosses like
henchmen like i don't even know what to
describe i don't even know how i don't
know the kid it was like it was like a
23 year old kid he's a [ __ ] loser
this is like but it was like a kid
sitting with clearly somebody that was
his boss like i would say an older
man
um who like may run chiller i don't know
and he was like sitting there and he's
sitting in his seat and he's just like
looking at what's happening well and
like he like taps him on the shoulder
and he's like all right
then started like physically like
bodying us out and i was like all right
no i'm gay i was like i'm leaving in a
second but that's nothing to do with it
that story is la in a nutshell yeah yeah
that's what i'm saying like i don't
think it was just that because we were
there super bowl week i feel like it's
not it's a hard time yeah it's a
hierarchy if you're not cool enough if
you're not a part of that crowd you
shouldn't be able to do it like the
following isn't yeah enough no
it's really bad and if you're not from
la and honestly i don't think i could
acclimate well in l.a if i wasn't
basically raised there my whole life but
people that move into there they have a
really hard time getting over here
because you need your crowd yeah no one
really you already know everybody there
you've made your friends you've got your
clients making new friends nearly
impossible i think east coast people are
way friendlier they they don't really
care so much about aesthetics looks what
you do for a job like they really just
want to have a good time yeah whereas in
l.a it's even the guys everyone's an
actor model i don't want to date someone
prettier than me yeah or in the sense i
don't like it
if
if you like if i were to take you guys
to like the bars i go to in in new york
you'd be like wait this is what you do
i'd be like i'm sitting on a bar stool
like watching like a basketball game
that's great but like no i know like yes
i know sometimes i feel bad like people
come to new york and they're like we
want to go out i'm like you're like this
is this i'm like do you want to go i
don't know if you want to go to the
places i want to go like i'm getting a
beer i'm watching the game we're good
yeah but i think that's kind of what's
nice is because ellie we don't we're not
able to go to bars and just chill yeah
but that's not the climate there like
everyone here is like oh let's go get
drinks after work or let's go to a bar
on a thursday whatever it is there it's
like if you're not going to bow a steak
house on sunset and they're going to
poppy after what the [ __ ] you're going
it was like we wanted to just cross it
off the bucket list
people watching what did you think it
was fun for people watching yeah that
and also
i thought it was like overrated like the
food wasn't great i thought i was like i
was like service was terrible yeah i was
just like
yeah it took us like two hours ago guys
everything in l.a is overrated
awkward in my opinion like we're like
standing up with our like mini weenies
like dancing and i'm like i'm like i
just want to like sit down
i don't know if i i i i don't know if i
should be dancing or i should be eating
like i'm just very young
like i keep standing up i always flip to
go to the bathroom because the floor is
so slippery i'm like i hate it and then
you can tell like the people there that
are like famous and cool or whatever and
then
we're there and
you're like they you can tell that they
don't want anyone like even stepping
near them no no jacob valerie was there
and we just got to look at it so that
was nice nice from a distance you know i
know i was like
but that would have been a good photo
that would have been a good fight that's
i think even worse is dating and i know
you guys both have boyfriends like how
do you think the dating climate is in
new york versus yeah
i feel like the the clientele one might
say is just different like you got a
bunch of financials
same douche different language yeah
exactly i feel like i feel like
different fonts they're different
different fonts they're like both cocky
but i feel like la guys are insecure
cocky yeah whereas new yorkers are just
la's comics dance and you know it's like
helvetica
like l.a i feel like compass but the
guys are insecure but want you to think
that they're not at all and they think
they're better but inside they're like
they're not we're in new york they
actually don't think that at all they
actually think they're better yeah like
you know
what's worse i don't know that story of
you guys going to hide is simply the
reason we have not gone to a club in
over three years yeah like you just
don't go out and i feel like when i'm in
new york i'm like wow i was telling
sophia i've had a cocktail every night
like there's so many places
in la like there is a feeling that like
so many people visit la and then they go
to these places and then in their mind
they're like oh my god i hope we see
someone famous tonight
they're looking around i mean i do it
when i'm in l.a like i'm looking around
i'm like who are we going to see
and we were not excited
i'm like hoping me too i'm like i've
been waiting for 25 years like what am i
going to see tonight exactly and in new
york like
you could walk into any bar any place
and people do not give a [ __ ] about who
you are and that's why it's no that's
great so many hidden gems too do you see
you like do you think you're going to
live here forever
no i think i might oh why and why no
i i just i mean i grew up in new jersey
and i
can't like envision myself
like raising kids somewhere else right i
don't know like if i would want to i
just feel more comfortable knowing that
i like know where yeah i am maybe i'll
live somewhere else short term before
that right we just went to san diego i
[ __ ] loved santiago do you guys like
it i love san diego oh it's a different
advisor i liked it but i just wouldn't
live on the west coast yeah but if i'm
gonna move anywhere yeah i would
probably move to florida yeah but it
would be florida new york
us why would we all move at yeah same
time yeah i love florida like i would
move there and it's so much fun i love
why not and yeah it's kind of like new
york except i don't not like new york
yeah i've just been here my whole life i
don't like
um i wouldn't say i don't like manhattan
i do like manhattan but i lived in
manhattan for a couple years and
um i felt a lot better when i moved back
home to long island just something about
it like i don't even know this sounds so
like just the energy around like i just
feel like there's just so many people so
you feel like i [ __ ] love i felt more
relaxed uh like being on long island
that's how i feel when i'm in new york i
feel like i don't know what my home base
is right yes and yeah there's so many
things to do that i would just go lay on
my couch cause i was like there's so
much to do that i actually don't want to
do any of it whereas now that i don't
live in the city we work in the city i
go out of my way to do things in the
city because i don't live there so yeah
i will find a cool restaurant to go to
right yes to go out right whatever but i
don't want to like sleep there for sure
right i get that i want to circle it
back to the podcast yeah um i was
reading an article on page six
and you guys are so big you have so much
exposure a lot of love comes with a lot
of hate and it was titled chicks in the
office reveal the creepy dms men keep
sending and this is sophie and i
we are so familiar with this yeah yeah
followers are men yeah most professors
are men
like way too kinky
like way too kinky
like i don't care at this point so um
what do they say to you guys because i'm
like trying to honestly wrap my head
around what could they possibly say bad
about you guys like you guys are just
like telling news in your experience you
guys want to just take my phone right
now and go through my dms like you would
what would be an example oh the younger
the older one i got last night was
really good shut up you [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's good
uh
it's a good mix i would say mostly
younger but see i'm trying to i'm trying
to differentiate younger like oh yeah
this one's kind of like i just don't
know what the [ __ ]
[ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ] you stupid [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's those are good ones wait
but this is
someone that person i want to see just
like oh it's really oh wait i'll show
you guys some good ones i was going
through last night where like it's
somebody with their kid like
someone that's a family man but i'm
trying to play
english i won't read this for one but it
starts off like hey you're the number
one [ __ ] like he's calling me a [ __ ]
and then it's his girlfriend or wife but
you know
and he follows me but that could be a
compliment you could read it like you're
the number one the rest of the rest of
the dm i know that he's
and then it was a girl and she was like
um
team shut up you skank
uh that's a crazy hashtag yeah yeah it
was very in-depth creative wait but i'm
do you think it hits like hurts more
when it comes from a young person or old
person
i think it
it it actually doesn't hurt me at all
anymore really because i've i feel like
i i nobody's ever really creative
anymore it's like i see the same thing
over and over again
i think it's more exciting
i would use shocking as the words like
when you see so-and-so's mommy cm's you
like you stupid skank you're like
somebody's mom is taking out the time to
do this and like when i talk to my
parents about it they're like imagine we
took out the time to say that to
somebody a young girl like to a young
girl and then like you see a guy with
his like young daughter in his profile
picture this happens all the time
it's like just kind of weird
creepy
right trying to hit on you being creepy
or
calling you a [ __ ] and it's like which
one is it right
you have your young daughter in your
picture and you're not even thinking
like when she grows up like imagine
somebody saying that to her like yeah
it's so insane have you guys ever
addressed that on your show like
to people listening stay away from it
only because anytime you bring more
attention to it it is an open invitation
for them to send you yeah like it's like
because
at the end of the day they're they're
people that are unhappy in their life
and they like are sending these things
if they hear you talking about them like
that's the attention that they're
looking for yeah exactly and so it's
just like it's not worth it like
everybody always jokes especially at um
at bar so like people year year after
year the idea to do like mean tweets you
know what jimmy come here like me yeah
yeah yeah they like are like why don't
you guys do like a mean tweets segment
and we're like no like every year it's
like because it's not like cause then
they're gonna get more creative
they won't stop so it's like why even
waste the energy
it's hard to not read them and i've
noticed with with my following it's it's
more um
what they want to do to us which is
really scary but all my tick tock
now those are guys
like like it's like
yeah fantasize it like dominating
because our dad is the worst was
recently there was a guy that was um
like messaging sophia like i'm outside
your bedroom window i can see it
like he was describing
yeah then what do you do about that you
can't do anything we tried to highlight
it
was fun
with anxiety like it elevates it and
trying not to read it but we have like
true perverse people that send stuff and
but they actually show up and they show
up and they actually like buy their
tickets they followed us to high school
before we were in milan working and they
came to milan they came to the show i
mean it's just like it's a
[ __ ] committed
i'm not sure if
our stalkers are committed they follow
through we love committed fans yeah yeah
you're not even mad you're impressed
physically like no they buy flights they
buy fights that's really bizarre i'm
sorry that you guys with that it's not
you know what it is
when you're in the public eye i feel
like it's just open season you kind of
are not you're not even asking for it
just you kind of have to expect it
because you're not going to be loved by
everybody everyone has like some opinion
about you yeah when they don't know
anything about you and i guess the worst
part about being even on a podcast or
anything like they think they're
entitled
to know who you are and feel like oh
yeah like this is what's the truth you
know what i'm saying like they
automatically separate you from being a
person with feelings since they're like
oh well she's a public figure like she
won't read it it won't hurt her right
and we try to talk about this on our
show because we do talk about so many
people and and topics and whatever drama
and it's like
you have to remind yourself and also the
people listening that we only know a
very small percentage of the story that
we're getting like there are so many
details in people's lives that you just
would have no idea about you never will
so it's kind of just like putting that
perspective and then then you can have
your opinions on whatever you're doing
yeah so what's next for you guys because
i know that you have a tour coming like
you just did we just finished yeah we
just want to show you guys gonna do
another round do another one please or
was that just so much because we're
definitely everywhere i think we will
but we'll focus a little bit back yeah
we're gonna take a break then we'll go
back to the east coast what was the
schedule like for you guys like how
often were you well excuse me
oh my gosh
we did two weeks on the west coast and
we did um
shows in san diego scottsdale san
francisco portland and seattle
and the first two stops were nice
because we kind of had like we had a day
show and then another day so it was kind
of like three days and then
we had that and we had that in san diego
that in scottsdale and then the next
week we did shows every other night so
we did tuesday thursday
saturday san francisco portland yeah
holy my brain
the reason i made that face was because
we before we did the tour
it was like all right we're gonna plan
to do all these things because yeah like
filming vlogs and then like i was like
guys imagine if we went to coachella no
no no no no
our original survival rate
our original plan was like oh it's it'll
line up perfectly we'll go to coachella
like the weekend before no and then
start the tour and then when once it got
closer i've gone before and i was like
guys i think this is the best idea
i heard this year was bad as well yeah
yeah
i was trying to factor in naps before we
even got like you're scared
full-blown meeting before we left of
like planning activities and she was
like i don't think i have enough time to
sleep yeah i was like when are we gonna
like factor in the naps here yeah and
they were like what are you talking
about we're only doing this one time and
then the middle of the tour hits
everyone's tired everyone needs their
rest i was like i told you we should
have scheduled then yeah
i was like i don't feel well i don't
care i am staying home that's important
the most important part of this trip is
the show yeah so yeah i don't care i'm
gonna focus on that and i'm gonna sleep
all day yeah but i think and all the
shows were great yeah the show they're
so awesome
because i always feel like with live
shows you're like all right people are
gonna show up well all right we sell
things beforehand so we like know how
many people were coming and we sold out
um all our shows besides that's so
awesome one of them was like just a few
tickets short but we could just say we
sold it out
right now the room was full yeah it was
cool to just see it and
on the west coast because you know it is
our fan base is more on the east coast
and just to see that we can reach that
fan base over there and then
with the east coast that we did in the
fall
um we did it like weekend by weekend so
it wasn't like a two-day trip straight
through yeah and we sold out each of
those shows within seconds and so we
were like wow we like sold ourselves
short so now the next one that we do
will be on the east coast and it'll be
like bigger way bigger oh well i can't
wait for that
to come yeah we want to do ones in
florida because our families we like we
were like why don't we we were like why
don't we just do a florida tour we'll
just hit five
oh yeah and then we'll go to a club and
we won't get pushed out of tables i
promise you that we'll have a good time
okay i love it so you're gonna plan a
tour of florida so we can hang out and
this exactly yeah thank you guys so much
for coming thank you so much for
watching guys plug where everyone can
find your merch your social medias your
podcast everything um you can follow us
on chicks in the office on instagram
personal instagram is maria chiffo
that's ciu ffo because i know nobody
will know how to spell that
you're right
um i'm at francesco mariano on instagram
you can go to the office you said that
yeah in the office you can go to
store.barcelosports.com and go to the
chicks in the office section shop all
our merch we got a lot of new birds
coming yeah it's a lot of fun by the way
i uh still wear your merch that you
grabbed me some years ago well you like
purple
we just came out with a new one i should
have gotten a new one by the way it
still holds up
all right well thank you guys so much
for watching this week and we'll see you
next tuesday